for uk travelers these days choosing a
european holiday destination is a game
of roulette
tonight another country added to the
quarantine list and by the week's end
the list could have grown longer at faro
airport in portugal
british travelers already booked on
flights were grateful to be getting out
with rumors rife that isolation on
return could be reimposed
we only had a small window to get out
here we booked it anyway
because we couldn't come earlier in the
year if they hadn't if we had
if couldn't get back we'd have been
fined by the schools and everything so
yeah it's really important that we get
back today
we did come when the quarantine was
still in place
and we had fingers and toes crossed
that it would be lifted which it was and
we were very pleased
and we're so so pleased that we're kind
of in the middle of this window
for those arriving on already planned
and paid for trips
simple frustration anyone would be
frustrated yeah i would be frustrated
but i'm hoping i won't be in quarantine
when we go back but and i think it's
really unfair
that they take the quarantine off then
everybody goes and books it
the situation here is causing confusion
and frustration for thousands of
travelers
who'd hope for a safe bet summer holiday
one of them is robin dunkley she and her
partner are due to fly to portugal on
holiday this sunday
but are now looking at cancelling very
disappointed
um we were kind of hoping that by
booking it just after they'd added it
or taking it off the list that we were
going to be quite safe
but obviously that's not the case so
it's going to be a mad rush to try and
find somewhere
to make matters worse they booked
portugal to replace their cancelled
wedding abroad
so we're supposed to be getting married
in las vegas in december
we made the decision to cancel that
and just book a holiday just to tie this
over till
next year but if uncertainty hangs over
portugal
absolute certainty has been given to
many britons now on holiday in greece
about what faces them on return those
flying into scotland will have to
self-isolate
the move comes days after all passengers
and crew on board a flight returning
from zante
were ordered to stay at home after seven
people on the plane tested positive for
covid it's a further blow for an already
struggling tourism industry in europe
and many travelers will now likely
ponder whether it's worth risking
going abroad at all michelle clifford
sky news
portugal